this is Jocko podcasts number 133 with
echo Charles and me Jocko will occur
good evening echo good evening and this
podcast will cover a horrific subject of
history and it is not for children or
the faint of heart
so listener discretion is advised
I am a war criminal I served in Manchu
Co that phoney country created by Japan
in 1992 a group of us went to China to
apologize to the family members of the
people we had sent to unit 731 one woman
now about sixty was the grandchild of
one of the victims
she told us our grandfather was killed
by unit 731 in experiments he was killed
because the Kempeitai sent him if you
hadn't sent him he would have lived
you are killers just like those doctors
we prostrate it ourselves an apology and
she kept pressing the fact home that we
were partners in crime as guilty as the
doctors of unit 731 and it's true it is
just as she said apologizing does not
erase the crime
we were the aggressors most of the
Japanese participants in the war were
aggressors orders came from above orders
from the Emperor then people were killed
because it couldn't be helped
according to International Convention
those who kill in combat are not
criminals the 3,000 people killed by
unit 731 were all sent there by the
Kempe Thai or the police the American
Navy was attacked at Pearl Harbor and
the Japanese thought it was a victorious
strike yet within two years America had
built up its naval strength again
America is a machine society but
bacteriological warfare does not rely on
machines so Ishii's idea was to kill the
attacking Russians with disease once
killed troops are not rebuilt like
machinery the Japanese army promised
Chinese children money for bringing in
rats the later gave them a pencil for
every rat the end purpose of all this
effort was war in war the side who kills
more people wins bacteria can kill on a
large scale
so Ishi pressed this forward
and that is testimony from a Ken TPI
officer which was kind of like a secret
police that served in Japan leading up
to and during World War two and this is
a part of history that I don't really
want to talk about no one does
but of course to ignore it to think that
if we pretend it didn't happen that only
opens up the door for it to happen again
so this is the story of unit 731 an arm
of the Japanese Imperial Army that along
with some other associated units they
developed tested and employed chemical
and biological warfare weapons and
there's two books that I reviewed and
will be referring to during this podcast
one is unit 731 by Pete Williams and
David Wallace and the other is unit 731
testimony by how gold and the history
and the acts that are counted for in
these books really show what man is
capable of especially on a malevolent
leadership and in this case the leader
that is primarily culpable for the
crimes of unit 731 as the individual
referred to in that opening statement a
guy named by the name of Ichi Shiro
Ishii who was born June 25th 1890 to the
fourth son and a wealthy land owning
family he was
a fairly very smart individual he was a
big tall kind of strapping guy then by
most accounts he was a pretty arrogant
individual as well and he went to school
to become a doctor and join the army and
there he studied bacteriology and
serology which is the the study of blood
and pathogens in the blood and he was
also a fiercely patriotic and
nationalistic individual and what that
meant in Japan at this time was a
feeling of total superiority both a
cultural superiority and a racial
superiority cultural and racial superior
superiority over the rest of Asia and
really over the rest of the world and he
moved up through the ranks fairly
quickly and he had done some traveling
and of course saw things that happened
in World War one and he saw chemical and
biological warfare as a way to win wars
and obviously Japan is a island nation
with limited resources and so you need
some advantage and he thought the
advantage that Japan could get was
chemical and biological warfare and in
order to really maximize that advantage
he believed that these weapons needed to
be tested on people he believed that
human experimentation was the pathway to
move ahead of the rest of the world
technologically in these departments and
oddly enough he gained a decent amount
of clouds and prestige by inventing a
water filtration system that could
provide clean water to soldiers
on the front line which was a really big
deal and and the book the book testimony
the unit 731 testimony goes into pretty
good detail about the number of people
that were killed in in wars back then
and how many of them would die of
diseases and malnutrition from being
sick from the water having diseases and
whatnot and so he developed this this
filtration system that worked really
well and he ended up actually taking
advantage of that a little too much and
he used that technology which he'd come
up with to get some kickback payments
from a commercial company that
manufactured the filters and that kind
of got him in some trouble but that
troubles overcome because he had some
political connections that he had gained
and he gotta got back on path and
continue to gain rank and gain stature
and with that rank and that stature that
he gained he convinced his leadership to
allow him to begin a highly secret
program where he would make and test the
biological and chemical weapons and
again at this time chemical and
biological weapons were very politically
sensitive so this is in the mid 1930s
the end of World War one had had only
occurred just prior to this really
twenty years and people remembered those
those wars that war and they remembered
the horrors of those weapons and and
that's why international law had
forbidden these weapons but he she
didn't care he she was there to win at
any cost and because of the view of the
chemical and biological weapons at this
time and the political sensitivity
around them he couldn't do what he
wanted to do inside of Japan because
these weapons are dangerous first of all
but again the political sensitivities
around them that was okay because he had
other plans
and he opened his first laboratory in
Manchuria an area of China that was at
this time under the brutal control of
Imperial Japan and the first laboratory
that he put together was outside of a
city called Harbin and interestingly the
unit maintained a level of cover meaning
there their purpose wasn't made known to
the world the people they advertise the
unit that they put in Manchuria that it
was all about water purification and
they and they actually did water
purification there so it was a good
cover story but what was really being
focused on underneath that cover was the
creation of biological and chemical
weapons that they could use for war and
as she made progression the project
expanded and now I'm going to go to the
book unit 731 by Peter Williams and
David Wallace
here we go in a few short years a she's
project had hurtled from relative
obscurity to one of top-secret and
national importance it took two years to
construct the establishments 150 or so
buildings which included accommodation
for thousands of people railway citing
an incinerator and powerhouse with tall
cooling towers and animal house an
airfield a large administration building
an exercise yard and a strange
forbidding square shaped building known
as road block ro the Japanese character
Row is square in shape hence the name of
the building
although row block looked square from
the outside hidden from view in the
center were two other buildings known as
blocks seven and eight row block was the
centre of bacteria production and
disease research block seven and eight
had a more sinister purpose unit 731 s
bacteriological research division was
divided into more than a dozen squads
each investigating the warfare
possibility of a wide variety of
diseases plague anthrax dysentery
typhoid paratyphoid cholera and many
other exotic and unknown diseases were
studied every conceivable facility was
given to unit 731 so that I think that's
important because they they were getting
a lot of money this wasn't like a little
rogue project that wasn't being
supported as a matter of fact here so -
were luxuries lavished on the lifestyle
of Ishii's researchers and workers in
the remote Manchurian plain at ping fan
a whole biological township grew up it
was known as Togo village so around this
unit 731 there's a whole village that
got created and they were all living the
good life by the way while Japan is not
living through the rest of Japan is you
know out getting ready to go to war or
at war in various parts of the world and
living lean here they're living large
back to the book Togo villagers had
plenty of
supplies of the best foods at times when
people in Tokyo were starving ping fan
was centrally heated against the bitter
sub-zero temperatures of the Manchurian
winter naturally it had the best
sanitation including even western-style
style laboratories so he took care of
his people and his people and he were
getting taken care of building a back to
bacterial weapon he found out was not an
easy task
he and his researchers faced a myriad of
problems what kind of microorganisms
would make a effective biological
warfare agent should it have a lethal or
incapacitating effect could it be
produced in quantities sufficient for
wartime employment could these living
organisms be kept kept alive through
storage and shipment to their ultimate
employment on the battlefield
what type of munition would be needed to
deliver the agent to the target what
were the technical and military
characteristics of such a weapon so he
started from Ground Zero trying to
figure all this out he approached the
problem by looking for weapons that
could be delivered from altitude by
aircraft causing massive outbreaks of
epidemics ever since his trip to Europe
play get fascinated Ishii and I talked
about his travel and this is their
talking a little bit about that here he
knew would make a deadly weapon if it
could be harnessed it is highly
infectious with an incubation period of
3 to 4 days sometimes up to a week the
onset is abrupt with chills high fever
and extreme weakness the eyes redden the
face becomes congested and the tongue
coated victims can become maniacally
delirious and death may be rapid
sometimes within one day compared with
some bacterial pathogens plague is only
moderately infectious but more virulent
strains can be cultivated
the plague could create casualties often
out of all proportion to the number of
bacteria disseminated he deduced
therefore that it would make an
efficient weapon set about preparing the
most dangerous strains and at some point
on this podcast we'll talk about the
black plague which is
an epidemic that was insane
in Europe but when you when you when you
have any knowledge about the Black
Plague and you read about someone that's
looking at it saying hey this looks like
a good idea you realize that this is
just a sick sadistic person plague had
another advantage for eg its origins
could be concealed science had not then
provided a satisfactory answer to the
age-old question of why where for how
long and how badly a plague epidemic
broke out so he thought this is great we
can cover it up a plague hits our enemy
and we you know we don't know where it
came from so they are producing this
they begin to produce this so large was
the production plant that in the heyday
of unit 731 it had the potential for
creating sufficient bacteria to kill the
world's population several times over
now that a she could produce plague and
other virulent bacteria in sufficient
quantities for warfare his next task was
to discover how he could deliver his
deadly microbes to the enemy and
obviously I'm not reading this entire
book and and there's more detail about
the process of getting to breed these
bacteria once they figured out how to
breed it and now we got to figure out
how to deliver it how are we gonna
attack the enemy with this he tries all
kinds of different things and then
finally back to the book his I had come
to rest upon the humble flea as in
nature so tune war this minut insect
could be relied upon as the carrier of
pestilence to yield vast quantities of
fleas and feed them enormous numbers of
rats had to be caught and bred this was
the job of unit 731 s Animal House run
by a she's elder brother meat sOooo
there's like a
as I was reading this there's like this
whole image of I mean are there you
think about the the reputation of rats
and fleas right rats and fleas are just
they're the worst right and and it just
paints this picture you just see rats
and fleas and this is what they're
breeding yeah this could this is like a
horror movie
yeah at back to the book at times of
peak production members of each force
were required to dress in civilian
clothes and go rat catching he found a
method suitable for weapons use here's a
description of this flea Factory the
second division had four special
premises for the mass breeding of fleas
in which a mixed temperature a fixed
temperature of 30 degrees Celsius was
maintained metal jars 30 centimeters
high and 50 centimeters wide were used
for the bleep breeding of fleas rice
husks were poured into the jars to keep
the fleas in after these preparations a
few fleas were put into each jar and
also a white rat for them to feed on the
rat was fastened in such a way as to not
hurt the fleas it's a horror movie but
this so there they're going through this
process of breeding fleas breeding rats
using the rats to feed the fleas and
raise the flea so if they can put these
fleas into containers and they're trying
out all different kind of containers and
how to drop them and how to spread them
and as they're figuring all that out it
they're doing other things as well and
it wasn't just rats and fleas there at
unit 731
back to the book hidden from the outside
world at the center of unit 731 s roll
block was a cheese secret of Secrets so
carefully was its existence kept secret
that many junior members of unit 731 had
no knowledge that it was there at all
for prisoners to pass through the tunnel
entrance was to start a journey of no
return
only two things were certain agony and
death
three of the Ishii brothers including
Takeo Mitsu oh and of course the
youngest Shiro worked at ping Fame
Takeo was the prison commander the
prison's guards were second or third
sons from the Ishii brothers village
kamo they were called the special squad
tied by bonds of peasant loyalty to
their Lord and Master they worshipped
him they called him the Honorable EC or
sometimes in reverence war God Ishi
most were uneducated but all were
unswervingly loyal to ensure allegiance
Ichi paid them extra allowances for
their terrible and dangerous duties the
sort of money sent home for which would
support whole families through difficult
times to come even pay for their
brothers and sisters education 'he's no
kmo villager has ever publicly spoken
even today about their former life in
Manchuria the village is silent the
Ishii family name is still revered for
its kindness asked about unit 731 older
residents were apprehensive Li reply I
have nothing to say because it concerns
the secrets of the Honorable Shiro Ishii
he based his unit in remote northern
Manchuria so he could experiment on
human beings there in what was a police
state he could be given an uninterrupted
supply of human guinea pigs with the
unique data gained from the human
experiments he she believed Japan could
outstrip the rest of the world in
developing this new weapon of war no
other country would have such accurate
details about how ech epidemics spread
or how to forget protect against them
only Japan would fully master the twin
fields of biological warfare offense and
defense from the earliest days he
appears to have employed human guinea
pigs
it was performed on prisoners who were
sentenced to death at Harbin prison each
prisoner was placed in a closely guarded
cell while the experiments took place
after death the bodies were burned in an
electric furnace to Leave No Trace by
1935 motion pictures of human
experiments were customarily being shown
to senior staff officers occupied
Manchuria and Harbin in particular was
an ideal location for supply of human
fodder and I should say that so it
started off they would use prisoners
that were sentenced to death that's
that's where it started but the supply
wasn't enough and it escalated from
there just to just abnormal people and
here's where it talks about that a
little bit back to the book occupied
Manchuria and Harbin in particularly was
an ideal location for supply of human
fodder Harbin a multiracial city of
shifting minority groups was a nest of
spies in addition Japan's occupation had
brought forth strong resistance from
both Chinese nationalists and Chinese
Communists as well as indigenous
Manchurians and Mongolians there was
also a large white Russian population
caught in the middle between communist
Russia and expansionist Japan to
maintain control in these difficult
circumstances was the job of this
Japanese Secret Service agency called
the toka mu ki Khan and the Ken P tie
they did so through brutal tactics of
fear anyone who voiced opposition to the
self-declared declared a paradise of
manchu CO was liable to detention many
never returned
the Japanese Secret Service guide to the
fundamental rules for interrogating war
prisoners reveals that world so this is
a document which I'm gonna read a couple
parts of of how you torture people there
their process for torturing people
number 62 sometimes depending on
circumstances it is advantageous to
resort to Church torture torture the
infliction number 63 torture the
infliction of physical suffering must be
sustained and continued in such a way
that there shall be no other way of
relief from suffering except by giving
truthful information torture is
advantageous because of the speed with
which it is possible with relative ease
to compel persons of weak will to give
truthful testimony testimony but there
is danger that in order to relieve
himself from suffering or in order to
please the interrogator the person
interrogated will on the contrary
distort the truth in the case of a
persons of strong will torture may
strengthen their will to resist and
leave ill feeling against the Empire
after the interrogation in relation to
persons of weak will torture is usually
applied in those cases when the person
interrogated does not speak the truth
even in the face of evidence but there
is full reason to suppose that this
person will speak frankly if torture is
applied it is necessary to bear in mind
that the methods of torture must be such
as can easily be applied as will sustain
suffering without rousing feelings of
pity and as will not leave either wounds
or scars so let's think about that right
there what they're saying is that the
torture has to be so easy to apply that
the person that's doing the torturer
won't feel sorry for them however in
cases where it's necessary to create the
apprehension of death the harm caused
the person interrogated can be ignored
but this must be done in such a way as
to not make it possible to continue not
make it impossible to continue the
interrogation after the application of
torture is necessary to convince the
person who has undergone the torture
that the torture applied to him was
quite a natural measure or to take such
measures as will induce him out of his
sense of pride sense of honor etc not to
speak about it after
so that's when you say hey look we
torture you you broke and you're weak
and you should be embarrassed about it
hmm number 69 nobody must know about
this application of torture except the
persons concerned with this under no
circumstances must other prisoners know
about it it is very important to take
measures to prevent shrieks from being
heard so they had their methodology they
had their standard operating procedures
to be a spy or dissident in Manchuria
was to risk death by firing squad or
decapitation but there was an
alternative far worse death at the hands
of unit 731 unsuspecting and innocent
people were also tricked into the
clutches of unit 731 some were lured by
the prospect of employment young boys
mothers and children even pregnant women
were trapped here's a a medical orderly
named issue boshy who carried out
checkups on and there's a word here
marutas and you're gonna hear what
marutas this is what they described the
people that are being held the prisoners
inside of unit 731 they called them
marutas or Morita singular and here's
what the orderly had to say about it
I started to work for unit 731 at age of
18 in the special section which did the
press on new prisoners we took details
of their blood type its pulse and
pressure and other things
prisoners were all referred to as
Marotta which is the Japanese word for a
log of wood although when they arrived
they had cards each with their name
birthplace reason for arrest and age we
simply gave them a number a Morita was
just a number a piece of experimental
material they were not even regarded as
human beings
most were between 20 and 40 years old
none were over 50 they seem to know
their fate we did terrible things so you
can see some obvious dehumanization they
don't call them people they call them
logs they give him a number not a name
very standard practice for
dehumanization back to the book the
prison was a vision of hell
through the spy hole cut in the steel
doors of each cell the plight of the
chained marutas could be seen some had
rotting limbs bits of bone protruding
through the skin blackened by necrosis
others were sweating and high fever
writhing in agony or moaning in pain
those who suffered from respiratory
infections coughed incessantly some were
bloated some emaciated and others were
blistered or had open wounds many of the
cells were communal an infected person
would be put in with healthy marutas to
see how easily did diseases spread
in desperation marutas would try to
practice primitive preventive medicine
to escape the diseases through these
little spy holes the most act the most
acute symptoms of the worst diseases in
the world were coldly observed by 730
ones white-coated doctors marutas were
used up at the rate of 2 to 3 per day
the dichotomy between the doctors true
vocation and the need to build a
medically based weapon was well and
expediently expressed by an individual
probably Ishii at the initial assembly
of unit 731 so this is a quote our
god-given mission as doctors is to
challenge all varieties of
disease-causing microorganisms to block
all roads of intrusion into the human
body to annihilate all four
matter resident in our bodies and to
devise the most expeditious treatments
possible however the research upon which
we are now about to embark is the
complete opposite of these principles
and may cause us some anguish as doctors
nevertheless I beseech you to pursue
this research based on the double
medical thrill 1 a scientist to exert
effort to probing for the truth in the
Natural Science and research and into
and discovery of the unknown world and 2
as a military person to successfully
build a powerful military weapon against
the enemy one young serologist doctor
Okimoto sent from the Tokyo Imperial
University to Manchuria by his professor
recalled the horror of discovering the
true purpose of an epidemic prevention
and water supply unit and here's what he
said I was very shocked when I arrived
and found out about the human
experiments very few of those scientists
scientists had a sense of conscious they
were treated they treated the prisoners
like animals the prisoners were the
enemy they would eventually be sentenced
to death they thought the prisoners
would die an honorable death if in the
process they contributed to the progress
of Medical Science I was very frightened
although my work involved no human
experiments I wrote my resignation three
or four times but there was no way to
get out I was told that if I left I
might secretly be executed so yeah there
and I this is covered in pretty good
depth in the book there was like a whole
recruiting process to bring the best
doctors and scientists from all the
universities in Japan up to Manchuria to
work there so these young kids are
becoming doctors thinking they're gonna
go out there and save people and the
exact opposite happens
back to the book syphilis was studied
many female marutas died as unit 731
endeavored to solve the venereal disease
epidemics raging through the ranks of
Imperial Japanese Army as its military
hordes marauded around the Asian
continent on one occasion a pregnant
woman was deliberately infected with the
disease and when her child was born
both were dissected cruel experiments
were not confined confined to the robach
five hours from ping fan by truck lai
anta proving ground unit 731 s education
division trees chief lieutenant colonel
nee she took part in one experiment here
are his comments an experiment in which
I participated was performed in
infecting ten Chinese War prisoners with
gas gangrene the object of the
experiment was to ascertain whether it
was possible to infect people with gas
gangrene at a temperature of 20 degrees
Celsius below zero this experiment was
performed in the following way ten
Chinese War prisoners were tied to
stakes at a distance of ten to twenty
meters from a shrapnel bomb that was
charged with gas gangrene to prevent the
men from being killed outright their
heads and backs were protected with a
special metal shield and thick quilted
blankets but their legs and buttocks or
left unprotected the bomb was exploded
by means of an electric switch and the
shrapnel bearing gas gangrene germs
scattered all over the spot where the
experiment EES were bound all the
experimental wounded in the legs or
buttocks and seven days later they died
in great torment
miraculously some marutas survived all
infection experiments developing
remarkable immunities but their fate was
always the same unit 731 had many other
uses for human fodder so they talked
about this in the book how some people
would develop immunity some guys were
just super tough just tough and in fact
there's one way they talk about they
they finally kill this guy after
experiment here's a 65 year old guy he
was just just tough he survived all
these different infections all these
different diseases and they they finally
when they kill him they they opened him
up they dissect him and they see that
he's like got the organs of a 25 year
old or something but it didn't matter
even if you were resistant to diseases
they had other experiments to do the
education chief Nishi had some other
recollections about some of those other
experiments back to the book with
temperatures below negative 20 degrees
Celsius people were brought out from the
detachments prison into the open their
arms were bared and made to freeze with
the help of an artificial current of air
this was done until they're frozen arms
when struck with a short stick emitted a
sound resembling that which a board
gives out when it is struck a film was
made on this subject to
here's another account of these so they
were they were trying to figure out
things about frostbite frostbite and
what people could take because they were
going to be fighting up in the steppes
of Manchuria and Russia they thought
they'd be fighting there so they had to
figure out new experiments to figure out
how to heal frostbite once it happened
and how much cold someone could take
here's a printer that worked there and
here's a account of what he witnessed
two naked men were put in an area forty
to fifty degrees below zero and
researchers filmed the whole process
until they died they suffered such agony
they were digging their nails into each
other's flesh this was military life you
couldn't say I want to do this or that
in war however good or bad the Japanese
way is to obey a superior it was the
same as if the order came from the
Emperor sometimes there were no
anesthetics they screamed and screamed
but we didn't regard the logs as human
beings they were lumps of meat on a
chopping block
the Japanese way is to obey a superior I
talk about that all the time you got a
question we've got a question continuing
detachment 731 had a sister unit it was
called the 716 chemical warfare unit
tests were carried out in a large cloud
chamber the size of a telephone box made
of thick steel it had an agitator in the
ceiling connected by large pipes to a
gas producing machine marutas were put
in a truck tied to a pole and pushed
inside some naked some in full Army
uniform and some in gas masks 731 and
5/16 researchers watched them gasp and
convulsed to their deaths through the
Chamber's reinforced a glass window a
young mother and her baby or even put to
death in this chamber she desperately
tried to protect her child from the
fumes by covering her it with her body
she died lying on top of her child
here's another account from a medical
orderly about other experiments beyond
cold and beyond chemical and beyond
beyond biological here we get to
malnutrition I saw malnutrition
experiments they were conducted by the
project team under the technician
Yoshimura he was a civilian member of
unit 731 the purpose of the experiments
I believe was to find out how long a
human being could survive with just
water and biscuits to marutas were used
for this experiment they continuously
circled a prescribed course within the
grounds of the unit carrying
approximately a 20 kilogram sandbag on
their backs
one succumbed before the other but they
both ultimately died the duration of the
experiment was about two months they
only received army biscuits to eat and
water to drink so that they would not
have been able to survive for very long
they weren't allowed a lot of sleep
either and here's one of the major
generals Kawashima and he talks about
the fate of some of the marutas from 500
to 600 prisoners were consigned to
detachment 731 annually if a prisoner
survived the inoculation of lethal
bacteria this did not save him from a
repetition of the experiments which
continued until death from the infection
supervened the infected people were
given medical treatment and ordered a
test of various methods of cure they
were fed normally and after they had
fully recovered were used for the next
experiment but infected with a different
kind of germ at any rate no one ever
left this factory alive
following anatomical study the bodies of
the dead were burned in the detachments
incinerator so as I said there's even if
you're just tough as nails they're just
gonna give you a different disease or
more disease and all pretty horrible and
now it gets worse
back to the book perhaps the greatest
horror of unit 731 was vivisection unit
731 had two teams of pathologists one
headed by dr. Okimoto
the other by dr. Ishikawa anatomical
study performed by these squads was not
always confined to the dead pathology
squad assistant Kiran
Sawa saw vivisections unit 731 did work
on living human bodies he said to do
this work our sentiments were suppressed
so this is a whole new level
we're actually dissecting or vivisecting
people that are alive back to the book
some doctors are said to have come all
the way from Japan just to see such a
dissection laboratory assistants got
extra pay called the chemical weapons
allowance for wielding the scalpel
during this dreadful work blood is said
often to spurted all over the ceiling of
the dissection room as certain incisions
were made limbs of the dying marutas
would flex and jerk involuntary oh
involuntarily as the scalpel entered
particular parts of the brain organs
would twitch vigorously after the
were thrown into jars of formalin for
preservation
not only were anesthetics researched but
also bizarre surgical experiments
connecting different parts of the body
are reported to have been performed so
yeah this is this is a horror movie
that's actually happening
you got selling different parts of the
body together this is just a horror
movie except this is not a movie and the
the people that are being referred to as
marutas right now our people back to the
book the world will probably never learn
of all the grisly experiments that took
place at unit 731
among them were pressure experiments
similar to those carried out by dr.
racer at Dachau concentration camp
presumably done on behalf of the
Japanese Air Force it was an extremely
painful method of killing individual
placed in the unit 731 pressure chamber
would suffer terrible agony as their
eyes first popped out of their sockets
as the eye membrane ruptured and later
as blood forced its way out through
pores in the skin
marude has had their blood siphoned off
and replaced with horse blood and plasma
experiments he was said the number of
these poor men women and children who
became marutas were mummified alive in
total dehydration experiments they
sweated to death under the heat of hot
dry fans at death their corpses weighed
only one-fifth normal body weight others
were electrocuted boiled alive killed in
giant centrifuges or died from prolonged
exposure to x-rays in all some 3,000 are
said to have been murdered some were
just killed off when there was an excess
of supply
they were killed like animals in AB in
an abattoir every bit of their bodies
mercilessly mercilessly used up in the
name of the terrible medicine of
military science
now as she went on with these
experiments he was he got worried about
something and this is what he got
worried about back to the book there was
a small but crucial chance that some of
his weapons might not work on American
or anglo-saxon racial groups in 1943
researcher Sumi was sent on trips to
Inner Mongolia to study the immunities
of Mongolians and other races another
had already been sent to a place called
Mouton so Mook tins another prison camp
so he got concerned that as he did these
experiments that some diseases affect
different races differently and there
was some chance that oh if we'd used
this type of bacteria against an
anglo-saxon or a white person it might
not work so we gotta we gotta figure
that one out well the Japanese had
captured Americans and Brits and
Australians so here we're gonna hear a
little bit about the prisoners in looped
in look I said is another prison camp
back to the book a warren w whelchel
known more familiarly as Pappy came from
Tulsa Oklahoma was a master sergeant
with the u.s. 200 200th Coast artillery
anti-aircraft regiment on April 9th 1942
Bataan fell on May 6th
so did Corregidor Pappy whelchel and
eighty-eight thousand other Americans
and Filipinos were captured Pappy
remembers it was the beginning of one of
the most dehumanizing experiences ever
perpetrated on humans well Joe and his
fellow prisoners had to endure the
familiar ill treatment
the Japanese meted out to prisoners of
war a proceeding that is understandable
only a few from the Japanese standpoint
that to die in battles honorable but to
surrender is to be shamed but is also
dehumanizing because unknown to him he
was
to become a human guinea pig in Japan's
experimental program as they sought to
build weapons of biological warfare well
to was to spend three years of his life
as one of the 1485 American and British
and Australian and New Zealand prisoners
of war who were herded into a special
prison camp in Manchuria at Mook Dhin
and of course they hyped their back to
the book the route that 1000 American
prisoners took to muten began with what
became known as the Bataan Death March
we were subjected to beatings killings
forced marches during the heat of the
day we were deprived of food water and
any medical attention whatsoever Pappy
whelchel remembered they were penned in
two camps in the Philippines hundreds
more died both in the camp and and from
suffocation as more than 100 crammed
into boxcars on the journey from one
camp to another then in October of 1942
about a thousand US troops had been
singled out and marched to Manila the
capital of the Philippines they went
aboard the Japanese vessel Tottori Maru
then here's a quote from the moment we
went aboard that hell ship they were
experimenting on us they threw us aboard
to see how much we could stand and how
many of us died they took us from the
tropics to a bitterly cold climate and
that took its toll on us they gave us
few crackers and little rice to eat and
I feel that it was a systematic way of
beginning to test us to found out to
find out how much the Americans and the
British and Australians could endure and
that was said by Gregg Gregg Rodriguez
senior now retired from his career as a
foreman in Henrietta Oklahoma Rodriguez
was a private in 59 coastal alter licor
US Army he survived the journey to Mook
tin and three years in the camp itself
now there's another guy
named Robert PD who was a senior British
officer and he was also in prison in
Mugen and he kept a daily diary or at
least he tried to keep a daily diary and
he kept it in code form but here's some
here's some of his entries into his
journal 19 April 43 another Japanese
medical investigated investigation
started today as apparently the findings
of the first did not meet with approval
24 May diarrhea is increasing 25 May
waiting for medicine for diarrhea which
was not forthcoming men were ordered to
exercise by playing baseball 26 may die
ignores of diarrhea consists of running
the men around the parade ground I saw
some of them with bare feet those who do
not mess their pants or drop from
exhaustion are reckoned to be liars and
are told to go back a protest has been
made and a change is expected in both
methods and personnel for June 3rd
Japanese medical investigation started 5
June anti dysentery inoculation 1/2 CC
including flescher
why 8 June diría still steadily
increasing 13 June 2nd anti dysentery
shot 1 cc 6 August there are now 208
dead
so as they're doing these experiments
and they've got these dead bodies of
American Australian British soldiers
they're still trying to utilize them
when they're dead to try and learn from
them back to the book one morning early
in 1943 Frank James was assigned to
burial detail this is of some of those
bodies I was pretty sick myself but I
wouldn't go to the hospital because
nobody that went in ever came out I went
round to the Hut and it must have been I
reckon three hundred and forty bodies
stacked there each body had a tag
attached to its toe there were two or
three men who I took to be Japanese
doctors there they were all masked a
hundred percent all the time they were
there their faces were covered another
fellow and I were told to lift up the
bodies and put them on the autopsy
tables then they began to cut them open
they went deep into the stomach the bile
the small intestine and they took what
looked like pancreas and lungs they also
operated on the heads and took part of
the brain so just a heart of a horror
show for the prisoners the end of their
incarceration in moonkin was quite
matter-of-fact and again this is a fast
forward and it also skips ahead a little
bit talking about how how the war ended
and what that was like after days of
rumor major PD's diary records for
August 16 1945 a six men were brought
into camp this evening and from the fact
that they were smoking more than the
regulation distance from an ashtray we
knew they were not prisoners of war
after an unusually good supper all
prisoners were released from the
guardhouse
then he continues on this is on 20
August at about 7:00 p.m. a small
Russian a small party of Russian
officers arrived and announced that we
are now free the Russian officer in
charge said here they are do what you
like with them cut their throats or
shoot them it's all the same to me but
this was translated diplomatically as he
says he hands them over to you for major
PD and the hundreds who had survived the
privations of MOOC Dhin the victory was
theirs in every sense they had no need
they decided to seek reprisals it would
have been said the major beneath our
dignity it would have reduced us to
their level after all they had to live
the rest of their lives with what they'd
done so the horror show ends and these
these soldiers that had been tortured
and killed murdered they decide they're
not even gonna take revenge because they
don't want to they don't want to lower
themselves to that level that's an
amazing but like I said that had skipped
the head the warm still wasn't over and
here we go back to the book he expected
the final and decisive battle would take
place between June and September 1945
when America attempted to land on Japan
proper Okinawa Japan's own Island
Bastion fell in June the month before
Germany had surrendered Russia urged by
Britain and America at Yalta turned
their attention to Manchuria for forces
swelled on both sides of the Soviet
Manchurian border as millions of troops
remained at standoff point
Tanaka's flea factory was expanded and
given more staff with 4,500 flea
breeding machines in operation a hundred
million insects could be produced every
few days he planned to breed 300
kilograms approximately
1 billion plague fleas in the run-up to
war special training courses in flea
breeding were set up at ping fain and
June and subunit members ordered back
afterwards to establish their own
production basis to propagate plague
cultures and to feed the fleas rats were
needed in their thousands Yamada ordered
every land unit of the Kuantan Kwantung
army to trap rats
Kurosawa's new conveyor system and again
I'm throwing names in here that are
explained with a lot more detail in the
book that's why you buy the book and
read the book so you can get the full
picture
Kurosawa's new conveyor system was
working round the clock producing plague
typhoid cholera and anthrax organisms
which were sufficient if correctly
dispersed to infect half the planet
between midnight and 1:00 a.m. on the
morning of August 9th after Hiroshima
had been devastated by the atomic bomb
the Soviet Army swept across the border
into Manchuria and Korea with a massive
force of one and a half million men
5,500 tanks and 5000 airplanes the
Kwantung army was thrown into panic
confusion broke loose that day or the
day after
Yamada ordered the destruction of unit
731 and 100 again 731 we've been talking
about 100 was another one of these
parallel units that was doing the same
type of stuff a nearby sapper unit was
ordered to blow up ping fens main
headquarters the unit's personnel were
to destroy all evidence and be evacuated
to sell Seoul in Korea a second bomb was
yet to be dropped on Nagasaki so here
the war is obviously turning we dropped
the bomb and they go to cover their
tracks they have to completely destroy
everything destroy the buildings destroy
all the records destroy everything and
when I say everything I mean everything
here we go back to the book at ping Phan
marutas were the first to be destroyed
members of the 516 chemical warfare unit
gassed the marutas by throwing flasks of
toxic chemicals into their cells 600
local Manchurian and Chinese laborers
who worked at the Yonezawa plant disease
farm and elsewhere a ping Fang were
machine-gunned potassium cyanide poison
was also put into the marutas breakfast
food so they're just trying to like I
said destroy everything and make it like
it didn't happen and as they wrap this
up the rest of unit 731 expecting a few
left behind for final clearing up
assembled on the 13th and 14th at the
shunting yard he made a formal speech
extolling the memory of unit 731 and its
diligent research as if in mockery of
him who was interrupted by the sound of
a prison exploding members were issued
files of
poison he had originally wished every
branch member in all families in Togo
village to commit suicide but this
proposal this proposal was met met the
violent disagreement of major-general
Kikuchi 731 s research chief nonetheless
some took their lives without orders
from Ichi so he thought they should all
kill themselves
got a little resistance there I would I
would have thought that kikuchi perhaps
would have provided more resistance
against the behavior that they were
occurring to not just to you just want
to protect himself here at the end hey
I'm not gonna question anything as long
as it doesn't affect me right that's
what that is on August 15th the Emperor
broadcast Japan's defeat and surrender
it had never occurred to Ichi that Japan
might give in he had to confirm the
broadcast before believing it such was
the shock that according to one account
he was seen in a listless condition
utterly crestfallen that day in the late
afternoon unit 731 train arrived at
Hince king there on the following night
he made a final address to the to his
Ernst wild troops he swore them to life
in the shadows for the rest of their
lives and the light of the candle held
by an aide-de-camp he ordered them never
to speak of their military past never to
take official positions in the future
and never again to contact each other it
is a promise that some have kept to this
day the pathetic end of Japan's once
mighty biological warfare effort was to
let loose thousands of infected rats in
the neighborhood of ping fan
it caused a local plague epidemic which
claimed many innocent lives into the
summer of 1946 a unit and a hundred a
handful of infected horses were freed
after the surrender
yeah you know you hear that argument
about the about the dropping of the
atomic bombs mm-hmm and the common
argument is always it would have cost
massive amounts of lives on both sides
Americans and Japanese because the
America Japanese were going to fight to
the death
and Americans were gonna kill them all
and so the best thing to do is like okay
we drop the atomic bombs this just kind
of makes that a closed deal in my mind
you know you got people that are trying
to got enough enough biological weaponry
to infect half the world so and again
jumping forward in this book get the
book so that you can get the whole story
but there's a a massive investigation
that takes place to find out what's
going on there's little leaks they fuck
they catch wind of a little bit of it
but not a lot of it and at one point
they're interrogating ishi and here's a
she she denied any involvement our work
was to protect soldiers he said did
anyone else concern themselves with
biological warfare against crop plants I
do not know replied Ishii his
interrogator made no effort to pursue
the matter Thompson a veterinarian by
training turned the questions of
biological warfare against animals we
did not do any experiments on log large
animals said Ishii we used small animals
as test animals besides we had no
veterinarians what field tests were made
with the plague organism
he asked due to the danger of it there
were no field experiments with that
organism there were great many field
mice in Manchuria and it would have been
dangerous to conduct field experiments
with plague because the field mice would
very easily carry the organisms and
start an epidemic we conducted the
experiments with plague in the
laboratory SETI XI what kind of
experiments Thompson inquired we put
rats and cages inside the room and
sprayed the whole room with plague
bacteria this was to determine how the
rats became infected whether through the
eyes nose mouth or through the skin what
did you find out the test results were
not too favorable we usually got 10%
infection by which way the
was the total said he/she
misunderstanding the question what route
was most effective Thompson repeated
through the nose said he/she also
through an open wound so they're
interrogating he's being pretty he's
lying
he's covering up but there's there's a
twist that we're gonna see unfold here
and I'll explain it a little bit so it
makes sense as it comes forth the twist
in this story is that the Cold War was
about to start the Cold War was now
starting and America you know these
experiments that had taken place and
knowledge had been gained through this
through these evil experiments well
America looked at the knowledge and
recognize our saw that there could be
knowledge that they didn't and that we
didn't have that America didn't have and
and decided let's try and get this
knowledge now one of the problems is and
again this is going to unfold but I'll
give a brief synopsis of it one of the
problems is if you charge someone with
war crimes and you put them on trial
well you've got to say what the wrong
what the war crimes aren't that they
committed and if you say that the war
crimes were committed or these
experiments with chemical and biological
weapons then people are gonna know what
the results of the experiments were and
that means the knowledge is gonna be out
there and the knowledge could fall into
the hands of people that we were now
looking to be facing in another war
which end up being a Cold War
luckily not a full war so that's how
this that's how this story continues to
unfold back to the book there's no
question that a she has an India as an
individual and many of his associates
were guilty of serious war crimes as a
lieutenant general a she was on a she
undoubtedly possessed sufficient high
military rank to be classified as a
class-a war criminal he was the top of
the tree in his own field his actions as
the head of unit 731 qualified him as a
criminal on many accounts
not only was biological warfare
considered extra legal by most countries
but issue is also guilty of outrageous
conventional war crimes he had carried
out calculated human experimentations on
prisoners of war a conventional war
crime that had long been prescribed in
the manuals of military law of every
major power heap carried out similar
research against innocent civilians
clearly a crime against humanity he had
taken his biological weapon out of the
research laboratory and used it in the
field he had sought autonomy and
independence of action for his
biological warfare forces throughout the
war zones he had done nothing to
restrain the conduct of his subordinates
so this guy is as guilty as they come
they there was other other events that
took place that were equally bad and
here we go some tribunals were held in
China the Philippines in the Pacific
Islands but most a total of 314 cases
were held at Yokohama Japan at these
courts a sufficient number of medical
atrocity cases were heard for them to be
considered as a special category the
most well-known and worst case presented
by legal section at Yokohama concerned
the fate of captured American fliers
held by the Japanese Western Army in
Kyushu after April 1945 the appalling
experiments to which they had been
subjected included vivisection and the
substitution of seawater for their blood
for this gross act of barbarism on
August 27th 1948 the nine Japanese
involved were convicted and sentenced
either to be hanged or to serve life
imprisonment one professor a Shyama of
Kishu university committed suicide in
prison so
clearly they had the attitude of like
we're gonna get some of these guys that
conducted experiments and that's exactly
what should happen and this was a much
smaller number of people that were
tortured and killed and uses human
experience than what was used it at 7:31
continuing on Cold War tensions had been
increasing throughout 1946 the desire to
mete out stern justice at the Tokyo
trial was increasingly subsumed if found
in conflict with the interests of
national security
Japan was in the front line so to now
was biological warfare on August 24th
1946 Washington cabled MacArthur
ordering him to protect intelligence
especially scientific which might
jeopardize America's national security
it read under present circumstances
intelligence relating to research and
development in the field of science and
war material should not be disclosed to
nations other than the British
Commonwealth biological warfare
intelligence seems by this time to have
become too much too sensitive to be
brought into the glare of massive of a
massive international trial throughout
1946 both Russia and America appeared to
have been reluctant to reveal their
hands in Japan America appears to have
taken some extra precautions to prevent
information from falling into Soviet
hands so you can see how it's unfolding
one of these again one of these senior
officers that has talked about deeply in
the book but I didn't discuss to too
much his name was NATO and here's a
quote from NATO we want to cooperate and
we owe it to the General Headquarters
but we have a responsibility to our
friends we took an oath never to divulge
information on human experiments we are
afraid some of us will be prosecuted as
war criminals we do not know how much
others will be willing to give us
if you can give us documentary'
immunity probably we can get everything
the subordinates not the section Chiefs
know all the details if we contact
someone who is a communist he is liable
to tell the Russians the Japanese were
given insurances that war crimes would
not be involved
MacArthur sent a five again fast forward
from MacArthur said a five-part radio
message to Washington showing the extent
of his knowledge it's clear from part
fine they have the whole the whole
message in the book is clear from part
five of the message that MacArthur
favored gaining the biological warfare
technical information by offering the
assurances that data would not be
employed at war crimes trials and here's
Ichi I will not reveal the information
to the Russians you can see how this is
unfold this is like one of those
horrible when a crime gets committed and
for whatever little technicality people
are getting off that's exactly what's
going on and you can hear it unfolding
and I mean does national security Trump
the it's almost like an ego move right
it's almost like an ego move you're
gonna make these guys pay it's also a
morality move and it's a justice it's I
guess it's beyond ego and beyond we're
out it's justice
these guys were criminals these guys did
heinous things to other human beings and
they should pay and as as strong as that
case is it didn't seem to hold up to the
case of national security we want to
have this information not that we were
going to use it but we better have it
better to have it and not need it than
need not have it's better to have it
yourself and not let your enemy have it
which is the Russians at this point yeah
so that's where the decisions getting
made yeah so you got to kind of consider
what's more important like this justice
yeah that's exactly the questions and
answers pretty clear what the quote what
the answer is is safety all right I mean
security you get all the justice yeah
you can get all the justice you want but
then it's gonna create some serious
problems in the future it's kind of you
know is it worth it yeah
and here's Ishii talking some more I
cannot give detailed technical data all
the records were destroyed I never did
know many details and I've forgotten
what I knew I can give you general
results I've never heard of anta that's
another base that they used until I
returned to ping fen in 1945 I did not
visit the location I am responsible for
all that went on at ping fan I am
willing to shoulder all responsibility
neither my superiors or my subordinates
had anything to do with issuing
instructions for experiments if you ask
me specific questions I can tell you
general results I am wholly responsible
for ping fen I do not want to see any of
my subordinates or superiors get in
trouble for what occurred if you will
give me documentary immunity for myself
superiors subordinates and subordinates
I can get you all the information for
you so he's he's making a deal he's
making me listen look I'm responsible
for everything and what he's doing is
saying look I'm responsible for
everything and if you give me immunity
I'll get you all the information you
want it's actually a good move it's a
good move on his part because he says
I'm responsible for everything even if
they say no we don't take a deal and
we're gonna hang you he's still he's
still trying to protect as many as many
of his people as he can up and down the
chain of command the advisability of
complying with Ishii's bargain war
crimes immunity in written form in
exchange for scientific data was to
occupy some of Washington's most senior
minds throughout the summer of 1947 he
continued Masuda Kaneko and nato whom
you say you know can give you a lot of
information I would like to be hired by
the United States as a biological
warfare expert in preparation for the
war with Russia I can give you the
advantage of my 20 years research and
experience I have given a great deal of
thought to tactical problems in the
defense against biological warfare I
have made Studies on the best agents to
be employed in various regions and in
cold climates I can write volume of all
biological warfare
including the little thought of
strategic and tactical employment god
this guy scumbag so it continues and
open back to the book and an open
admission about human experimentation
allegations about the the use of
biological warfare even hints about the
connection between unit 731 and a member
of the Japanese Imperial Family were all
contained in the files of legal sections
case 330 by the middle of 1947 how did
this come about and why was nothing be
done being done about the files contents
so this is getting shut down that's
what's happening now here's the sort of
the more official opinion back to the
book on balance the subcommittee felt it
was desirable to avoid a war crimes
prosecution and here's what they said
since it is believed that the USSR
possesses only a small portion of this
technical information and since any war
crimes trial would completely reveal
such data to all nations it is felt that
such publicity must be avoided in
interests of defense and the security of
the United States it is believed it is
believed also that war crimes
prosecution of he and his associates
would serve to stop the flow of much
additional information of a technical
and scientific nature it is felt that
the use of this information has a basis
for war crimes evidence would be a grave
detriment to Japanese cooperation with
the United States occupation forces in
Japan so there you hear the decisions
getting made and that's the way it went
and in the end going back to the book no
member of unit 731 was called before any
British or American military tribunal to
account for war crimes
none of them
well actually not buy any British or
Americans because the Russians they
still went after and they and when they
went after him then they got some of
them they they made America look bad hmm
they had a big trial and here's the the
state council the state councils name
was Smirnoff and here we go back to the
books Smirnoff
spelled out a message intended for the
ears of an audience thousands of miles
from the courtroom
these men he and the rest now he she
wasn't a part of this trial but he and
the rest enjoy the protection of those
reactionary forces in the imperialist
camp who are themselves dreaming of a
time when they will be able to hurl upon
mankind loads of TNT atomic bombs and
lethal bacteria the accused received the
sentences as follows and then they
listed these guys that various soldiers
and civilians that served in some of
these biological warfare experimentation
centers they got 25 years 20 years 18
years 15 years 12 years 10 years 2 years
3 years
but again those sentences don't include
a she or the other main players at unit
731 because they got kind of protected
not even kinda they got protected by
America in exchange for their
information sort of in response to
everything that was going on there on
December 27 1941 the following story
appeared in The New York Times date
lined Tokyo no knowledge MacArthur says
general mccardle Douglas MacArthur's
headquarters said today there were no
known cases in which Japanese used
American prisoners in germ warfare
experiments the headquarters added that
the Japanese had done some experiments
with animals but there was no evidence
they had ever used human beings as far
as is known here no Americans held
prisoner by the Japanese that mook
didn't ever accused their captors of
having used them as guinea pigs in
biological warfare
tests so that's all not true mm-hmm
that's all not true
back to the book to this day Russia has
allowed itself to bask in feelings of
more moral superiority over America and
not without some justification in
respect of the way it brought its unit
731 criminals to justice
so just that's the way that's the way it
flushed out now this you might think
that's a little disturbing this is
equally disturbing this is just horrible
back to the book after the war most of
the scientists of unit 731 prospered
much is explained by the clear
complicity on the part of the United
States authorities in the war crimes of
unit 731 the detachments civilian
researchers and other associated
scientists were quite free to return to
academia and it goes through this lit
this multiple page lists of of guys that
went on to work at the Research
Institute for Natural Resources chief
and yet another guy was chief research
section at a pharmaceutical company
doctor Ishikawa wants a pathologist at
unit 731 who had brought home within
thousands of human pathological samples
became a professor at at a university in
1944 a position he held throughout the
1960s and 70s he eventually became
president of the University's medical
school the local newspaper once planned
to award him with a medal for his
contribution to society but after
students who knew of his wartime record
objected the war was cancelled so these
guys carried on another guy professor of
show a University of pharmacological
another professor of bacteriological at
Kyoto University
the list goes on and on
dr. he Sato Yoshimura who directed unit
731 frostbite experiments literally
freezing people to death became a
faculty member of the kyoto prefecture
all medical college in the 1950s and
later its president and like i said that
list goes on and on and on and of course
we still haven't heard about it yet the
mastermind behind this whole thing
here we go back to the book he inherited
much of a family's property in kamo
village because you remember kml
villages where they bring all these
prison guards from their home village so
that they'd get the complete loyalty
from him so he inherited much of the
properties family the family property in
kamo village his two elder brothers
Takeo and Mitsuo were childless
unlike Shiro who fathered six children
Takeo unit 731 special prison squad
leader eventually died of liver cancer
in Kobe the city whence his second wife
had come Mitsu oh who wants to revise
the the unit's Animal House outlived his
younger brother Shiro but was unable to
work after the war and lived on money
gained by selling his country property
with solo
masuo and Takeo and their eldest brother
Tyrell who had been killed in the
russo-japanese war during Japan's Meiji
period are buried in the Ishii family
cemetery at kamo on August 17 1958 13
years after the end of the war in the
back room of a stonemason shop near
Thomas cemeteries Tokyo he made his
first and apparently only post-war
appearance before assembled the junior
members of his former unit he reminisced
about the early days of unit 731
in a speech reportedly still rich in
xenophobia and elitism he described how
his unit was to have been
elevation of Japan a country then
encircled by the West
scientifically impoverished yet
spiritually rich he apologized for their
suffering since the end of the war but
urged his audience to remain proud of
the memory of unit 731 then here's a
little part of his what he said it was
in order that we could have precious
human material that the unit 731 was set
for the saving of the nation national
circumstances were not permitting
unfortunately we did not achieve our
aims so even after all that even after
all that even looking back after 13
years after the end of the war he's
looking back and still has the same
mindset and that mentality is hard to
understand I want to shed a little bit
of light on that mentality and do that
through some personal accounts of what
happened at unit 731 and that's from
this other book it's called unit 731
testimony then let's go to this book and
I think these make it pretty clear where
this mentality comes from so this
account is from a captain in the
Japanese Imperial Army named Kojima
Kojima TKO and here we go perhaps there
are some people here and and by the way
most of these accounts are from an
exhibition that went around Japan kind
of explaining what happened and people
would come to this exhibition then they
would capture if someone was involved in
unit 731 or someone remembered her
someone had a story about it they would
capture their account and that's what
this book has a lot of from this expert
that this exhibition that they did I
think was in the mid-1990s that they did
is exhibition so this particular person
that was showed up at this exit
he was a captain in the Japanese army
his name is Kojima Keo and here's what
he said perhaps there are some people
here at this unit 731 exhibition who
think that this was all there was to
Japan Japanese aggression at the time
unit 731 was merely one segment of the
dark shadow of Japan's aggression and I
would like to tell of my experience in
this and I think this is why I pulled
this one specifically because this talks
about where this came from where this
mentality came from that he/she had to
the end we were born and raised in a
society of M / ISM a person's absolute
responsibility above the army and
government was to the Emperor the
Emperor was a living deity the Emperor's
command was supreme and controlled the
entire country we were told how we must
serve the Emperor how we should behave
toward our parents how should we should
behave toward our teachers and house we
should behave toward our siblings we
were taught that Japan is a sacred
country that the people of Japan are a
superior race that the people of China
Korea Southeast Asia and Russia were all
inferior races and the superior race
must govern them and by doing so we
would bring them happiness this was the
cause to which Japan must devote itself
he goes on again I'm not reading the
entire thing but you have to get the
book to get these entire accounts soon
after we went into service we were given
training to get our courage up we were
ordered to watch beheadings Chinese were
made to sit by a hole in the ground and
the seasoned soldiers would cut their
heads off blood spurted up from the neck
into the air and the bodies would roll
into the holes then we had bayonet
practice victims had their hands tied
behind them around a tree and were used
as bayonet
targets we had to watch this as part of
our training this was a shock to me and
for two or three days food would not
pass through my throat but two years
later I became an officer in charge of a
platoon and with about 25 men under me
later I became a company commander with
151 men and that meant that if I didn't
build a strong platoon and a strong
company I would fall behind and so I too
tested the courage of the soldiers under
me by using Chinese prisoners this was
normal training in the Japanese army
when we were not involved in major
operations we would go out into our own
immediate area on continuous 3-day
operations
to see if there were any enemy around on
such occasions we stole tortured and
slaughtered people the Chinese had a
saying about us that Japan had a
threeway complete policy burned
completely killed completely and
pillaged completely yet when we were
doing those things we had no sense of
guilt or of doing anything wrong it was
for the Emperor for the country
so that's how they're raised and that's
how you can end up with someone like a
she that goes through all that and still
remains loyal even after defeat still
remains loyal to the deposed Emperor and
here's an army doctor named Yuasa
Ken this is not easy for me to speak
about but it is something I must confess
what I did was wrong it is also true
that it was forced on me by the
government but that does not reduce the
size of my crime it is something that
happened a long time ago but those who
are not taught about the war are alleged
the Japanese armored army went to ponder
and steal materials and to kill Japan
won an iron coal and provisions and the
army drove into the mountains to
prosecute the war at the time the
Japanese used derogatory terms for the
Chinese like Chinamen and chink and
looked at them with contempt when I was
a child we were told to despise the
Chinese despise the Koreans it's alright
to conquer them we have become elite and
should join with the Americans and
British and conquer Asia I hated war and
killing but around middle school and
into college I began to think that such
ideas were unavoidable people were
driven into a life which human qualities
in which human qualities were lost
the soldiers outlet for frustrations was
the brothel of the comfort women any
means was resorted to in order to raise
ones rank and keep up the authority of
the country
and in the army hospital we practiced
vivisection living persons are good for
the scalpel practice so people were
brought in one day soon after I started
at the assignment the hospital had told
us today we will have surgery practice I
was startled it was an order there was
no getting out of it normally we
dissected people who had died of such
diseases as typhoid fever dysentery and
tuberculosis now we were being taken to
the dissection room for a different type
of exercise soldiers came along as
observers everything started with a
signal from the hospital head one
Chinese had big thighs and walked slowly
and calmly he laid down and had no sign
of fear no stress on his face he was
composed someone else used him for
surgery practice I went over and pushed
the other one onto the operating table I
had no feeling of apology or of doing
anything bad the farmer was resigned to
his fate and he lowered his head and
walked forward I didn't want to get my
clothes dirty from him I wanted to look
sharp
he went down as far as the operating
table but didn't want to lie down a
nurse using broken Chinese told him
we're using ether it won't hurt so lie
down she gave me a wry smile when she
said that she had been working there for
a long time and when I happened to meet
her again much later and asked her about
it she didn't remember she was handling
so many vivisections
it was routine people who repeat evil
acts do not remember them there is no
sense of wrongdoing war means this also
war is not just shooting in order for
Japan to win all the Chinese were made
prisoners women's bellies were cut open
homes were burned if you couldn't do
this then you weren't a loyal soldier of
the Emperor even if one despises an act
one must bear it from there a person
becomes accustomed to it we all received
practiced it was normal to smile at this
the crimes committed during our
aggressive Wars are forgotten gone from
memory at the time they were considered
right so the surgery began the man was
given ether and dissected his appendix
was so small that it was like looking
for a burrowing worm I had to cut in
search repeatedly the blood flow was
stopped nerves were cut bones were cut
with a saw and a tracheotomy was
performed blood and air escaped from his
body the blood came foaming up practice
time was two hours the man died and his
body was thrown into a hole and buried
that was my first crime after that it
was easy
eventually I dissected 14 Chinese I also
saw vivisections once I saw about 40
doctors gathered there was a man bound
and squatting the guard asked the
doctors are you ready and the prisoner
was laid out without anesthetic two cuts
were made down his belly the victim made
a few gasps the dissection was a botch
and he died soon I saw four people
dissected that way it is said that there
are that there were twenty million
victims of the war in China but only 10
to 20% of these were killed in gunfire
exchange
most non resisting old people women and
children were captured and slaughtered
prisoners of war could not be taken to
the front or allowed to escape so they
were killed in the manner of The Rape of
Nanking those who were a part of it
do not come forward to tell the people
how it was why because the Japanese had
forgotten all about it everybody's
forgotten they did things and got medals
and they don't think they did anything
worse than kicking a dog
they weren't bothered because they never
considered it a dreadful thing to take a
scalpel and cut open a living person
and this will be the last piece of
testimony that I read and this was a
soldier that was attached to unit 731
named O'Hara takayoshi and he said I
joined the cavalry from my home in 1939
in April of that year I was stationed in
northeast China then in March 1942 I was
transferred to unit 731 I did not know
anything about that unit my first duty
was taking care of domesticated animals
such as sheep goats horses and cows I
assisted in researching the diseases
that affect these animals
I saw tests in which Marotta were tied
to crosses in a large circle as planes
flew over and dropped bacteriological
bombs in the area surrounded by the
crosses their legs were chained and
their bodies tied tightly we observed
the tests from a distance of about 200
meters I had the job of cleaning up and
disinfecting after the experiments and
gathering debris lying around I want
people who come to this exhibition to
tell their children and grandchildren
that there is nothing more stupid and
fearful than war
I want people to tell their children and
grandchildren that there is nothing more
stupid and more fearful than war nothing
more stupid and fearful than war then I
think that's a good quote to end this
except for it is wrong it is wrong
because as stupid and as fearful and as
reprehensible as war is there is
something worse than war and that is
allowing this kind of evil to exist as
bad as war is and war is awful war is
hell and I have said that over and over
again as have many others but there are
worse things than war
things like unit 731 things like the
Nazi concentration camps things like The
Rape of Nanking there are things that
are worse than war and there are times
when war is not only justified but it is
a moral obligation and I do not say that
lightly
but when evil and when darkness and when
malevolent and demonic spirits rise to
power they must be stopped then the
responsibility for that lies within all
of us every day to do our best to do our
best to move the world away from the
darkness and the demons that linger
inside men's minds they move the world
toward the light and toward what is good
and I think that is all I have got for
tonight so echo Charles mm-hmm I think
while I decompress a little bit if you
could talk about ways for the crew here
to move towards the light mm-hmm I'm
gonna try yeah I know I know
and if you think about originally mm-hmm
when we started getting into these kind
of podcasts that touched upon some very
heavy some very disturbing subject
matter that was that was where the whole
sort of exists let's call it extended
closing to the show began yeah kind of
yeah could just and and I remember like
I remember like the first time I said
you like a man you just talk for a
little while
I need to break over here yeah that's
how we ended up with this this thing
yeah but then the interesting thing
people would say hey thanks for doing
that yeah cuz you're not the only one
that needs to decompress after you hear
this freaking crap yeah after you hear
about this just heinous evil yeah that
really happened yeah we need a little
break we need a little echo Charles here
too you know yeah that's that's rough
where you you know you go from
vivisection you know and then what if
you were like hey all right that's all I
got for tonight
yeah like that yeah then you kind of
already turned off you go into I don't
know work or whatever whenever you let's
do it go to bed no that's that came out
with with 121 122 and 123 with Louie
polar and with chesty puller Louie
puller and then Jake Schick I wasn't
gonna do I could I said to myself I
can't do 121 and 122 and just leave 122
out there in the world by itself
I need Jake Schick my brother
come on in like know that you can get
through that yeah you know and so this
is kind of the same thing you know I
just can't like walk off yeah yeah mic
drop and then yeah you guys deal with it
now no we're gonna deal with it together
that's okay we're gonna have that go
Charles help us do it it's all come back
little bit a little bit a little bit try
China can't forget I mean it's me you're
not gonna forget that you know anyone
just like you can't forget machetes
season you can't forget the reaper
thinking nothing so you're gonna
remember but can't forget the new i'm
ask her yeah and the harsh i mean just
it's it's it's crazy yeah but yeah man
Oh far be it from our intention to leave
you with bad feelings that last we want
I've said this before right we want you
to remember but not dwell yes right I
think that's important you know you're
dealing with loss I mean I talk about
that a lot when you're dealing with loss
yeah you always want to remember the
people you've lost but you can't dwell
on it yeah and you always want to
remember The Rape of Nanking you always
want to remember
machete season you always want to
remember unit 731 you always want to
remember man search for meaning you
always want to remember meal I'm a skirt
you want to remember those things cuz
they're real and they happen and they
can happen again if we let them yeah we
can't dwell on them because there's
there's because you know what we one
good one and good will win yeah what I'm
thinking yeah fully you know okay
there's this movie something about a
centipede maybe literally no possible
way I've seen this movie but yeah I've
never seen it I've seen the the the oh
is it completely like psycho sick
disturbing scientist guy so you know I
can't help but kind of think it's when
you said this isn't a movie this is this
really happened and that's really the
hard part when you really start to think
about it as like just like how we're
sitting here right now what's using the
restroom
really hard is you know you you picture
the mother in a gas chamber with her
baby and you you can't just picture a
mother you can't just picture a child
you have to like picture a mother and a
child that you know you need to put that
in you need to picture someone that you
because you can't you can't make that
connection maybe saying a mother and a
child that that doesn't that doesn't
bring it together for you they actually
have to picture someone you know and
their kid being that's what you need to
picture being forced because that's what
those people were they were people with
but they were people with alive in there
had hopes and dreams and all those
things and they got put into a gas
chamber to see how long they could last
without a gas mask that's what you have
to picture yeah yeah it makes the point
for sure what oh here's a moral question
okay you know how like some of these
doctors and scientists they went on to
be prosperous you know I've you know
after this deal and they obviously I
mean apparently some of them did some
really good work where they're getting
like the awards and whatnot and you know
what speaking of this I was thinking
about this because another really dark
book that we covered on here was
ordinary men in which ordinary men
talked about the the palete that the
Nazi police that went from being normal
guys that were middle-aged hadn't been
indoctrinated in the Nazi way of life as
children they got kind of like swept
along with the rest of the Germans and
they ended up committing these heinous
acts and and murdering thousands and
thousands of Jews but what's interesting
about that so in that story it's normal
guys going evil in this story these evil
guys that did evil things they come out
the other side and kind of like go
normal right and then they it's just so
did they didn't they get kind of they
got forced into it though right remember
they were like hey hey you got to do
this or you die they did get well not
really
if you remember in ordinary men their
commander action in the beginning is
like hey if you want if you don't want
to do this go home right
I mean the Japanese members there's
definitely some guys getting forced into
it yeah so you hear so here's the moral
question it's like okay of course you
know these guys committing crimes
regardless of you know the the
surrounding circumstances they committed
these crimes of factual and then they
kind of get away and then they get into
normal society in there and they don't
get punished right perceived like no
justice right no justice but so here's
the moral question so duh is it did they
make up even a little bit for their
crime by doing good in the future even
though they didn't get punished like did
they make up for it or is it more of a
crime because they got to do good stuff
they got to get Awards and they got to
be prosperous yeah they shouldn't at the
end either what if you look at it from
the perspective of like hey let's look
at them whole it so there's there's two
ways I'm gonna stage this for you look
at it holistically from like okay here's
this person let's look at it from my
from Jacko's perspective here's this
person they did these horrible things
but now they've kind of got back on
track and they've put their life
together and and that's that's a
positive thing and they've even if you
can't make up for that whole crime at
least you're chipping away at some of
the horrible things you did and
replacing it with something good and and
you can see where people come to the
conclusion that like well okay I can
kind of see how that makes sense that's
one way of looking at it or others too
by the way not just necessarily got to
do all this but if they're doing good
work scientifically and for you know
medical schools and stuff like this is
obviously they're teaching people
they're probably you know making
breakthroughs and you know discoveries
in the field and stuff that's gonna help
people in a neural you know now here's
the other way I'm gonna frame it for you
is from the eyes of that mother who's in
that gas chamber
who's watching that switch get turned
and she knows it's gonna kill her and
her child and there's no there's no
redemption zero
check good job trying to lighten up the
mood over here yeah well you will amen
you know all right
well hey let's talk some support support
Welling weird well we breaking our what
we're breaking our our own code here
okay weird welding bit code yes all
right well let's talk about origin I
feel like we should talk about origin
and the first thing about origin that I
will talk about is the geese the
flagship product is all made in America
by the way rash guards as well this is
for jiu-jitsu by the way specifically
but not limited to so while the guys are
kind of limited to unless you want to
make it dragon we suit like you're the
one who recommended you know you can do
judo in it you know yeah I guess
technically you do karate too if you
want
technically I mean but they're made for
jiu-jitsu the rash guards made for
jiu-jitsu but you can use it for like
cycling and body boarding and whatnot
yeah anything that you want to protect
yourself from rashes not
juror masses like rash rash is actually
it does have antimicrobial stuff in it
is true so it is kind of predictable
anyway or gene mean dot-com that's where
you can get this stuff all made in
America and also joggers coming from the
connoisseurs comfort himself that's me
people are self comment about that yes
your your now becoming known yeah maybe
you could parlay that into like a whole
thing yeah like a whole thing things for
comfort establish a standard of comfort
it'll be called the connoisseur of
comfort scale see I'm saying you know
how like in temperature there's like
Kelvin yeah Celsius Fahrenheit yep I'll
be that for comfort the echo scale yeah
echo scale of comfort what would the
highest level of comfort be would it
just be one to ten you know I'd be uh uh
oj oj would be the highest what's a
ranking oj Origen joggers Oh dad
I'm over here I'm like I'm get Pete for
some reason he's the kind guy I like to
just call you know how you like you'll
text someone you know really I wanna you
don't really but nowadays we like to
text yeah yeah you know I'm not gonna
bother them I'm not gonna you know but I
know for some reason I like to call Pete
so call him and I'll be like hey when's
the shorts coming up not first so we can
you know do because I want to wear them
you know that kind of stuff anyway so
I'm about to call him and be like hey we
need more colors of joggers or whatever
but here's the thing
Dewey I need more colors today so I
can't just be running Pete around his
factory making new colors just for me
personally or maybe again I don't know
but it would help but yeah they're real
good joggers uh t-shirts and hoodies and
whatnot good stuff mate margin Maine
Marine American in America yeah which is
good on a whole bunch of different
levels also we got a bunch of
supplements we got joint warfare
we got krill oil we got discipline which
is good to drink before you get after it
mentally or physically and also we got
milk yeah but back to joint warfare okay
so let me keep it I know you you're
wondering how my arm is doing I know
I'll let you know so I went to Oregon
the Oregon Coast last week one week
forgot the joint warfare I just had
surgery on my bicep about six yeah six
weeks ago and you know we you know I
would have FedEx truce on bro
I know but yeah and thank you but you
know it's how long does it take before
you notice it I'm guessing the moral of
the story this didn't work out yeah so
and here's the thing my surgeon is good
he was good he did a good job on my
reattached my bicep tendon to my bone
drilled the hole in the bone boom stick
it through sew it up cuz she gets good
shelter right so I take joint warfare
the thing feels good like I'm away I had
a schedule you know surprisingly because
I had it done in my line years ago blah
blah so it's all good I'm moving or I'm
doing like push-ups doing stuff that no
way I could get I could have done with
booth
so I got it Oregon Coast forget the
joint warfare I tribute to the joint war
for how far I am
so I forget the joint warfare I'm in the
Oregon coast I would say about two days
and here's the thing in start like
hurting or going backwards nothing tup
but it was just this weird stiffness
that sorta disagree like I couldn't
straighten it out right away when I wake
up you know I can't like you know I kind
of got to work it out and it slowly just
started to just stiffen up a little more
and here's the thing I was way less
active on it to where cuz when I do like
push-ups and stuff where I'm using my
elbow a lot it would be kind of stiff
that night you know then the next day
you sit up and then it's stronger you
know it's just one of those thing like
muscles but it's my train so I wasn't
doing that not much activity and it was
just general stiffness I don't want to
say it felt inflamed but it felt like
you know you know like you sprained your
thumb or something like that and it's
like swollen and it's like just jammed
up you can use it but anyway it kind of
felt like that functional but not
optimal functional but not not optimal
and then I come back two days back on
the joint warfare boom back in the game
that's full-on back in the game that's
pretty cool it yeah it's real for a hell
of a thing man good supposed to mean
chondroitin curcumin good for your brain
too by the way yeah just like discipline
yeah also mulk as you were saying yeah
what up with mom well there's first of
all marks awesome second of all what is
milk it smoked everyone knows that now I
think that's pretty much gonna be the
new thing and we have peanut butter
chocolate will be coming out I wanna say
a week I wanna say within a week you're
all like yeah we have our brother and
Chuck we have peanut butter and
chocolate coming in about a week yeah
maybe no no it's not even maybe go
straight up one weeks having done the
deed okay that's good so Molk protein
how many how much you how many grams of
protein a moment you know 20 to 3 scoops
so and I heard this I recently actually
I didn't read it I saw it on a video
YouTube video I know that sounds like or
YouTube video but I say this one had
credibility so
you know so you need that me but a good
amount of protein is one gram vapor they
thought it was like 1.5 you trying to
build muscle all this stuff oh it is
changed it's about its weight according
to this YouTube video
it's like point seven for something like
one point that's for heaven I don't know
honey more than that I'll tell you right
now all right well there you go malt get
it and it tastes good real good
by the way it's dessert yeah eating is
more classified as a dessert that's the
question yes currently it is currently
that's how I classify to even oh I
literally eat my dinner and then I'm all
excited to have more and what I went on
the trip and I haven't figured out how
to travel with milk yet which is a real
bummer but you know it's it's scoop you
can't bring six scoops and I'm real
light traveler yeah and so now when I go
somewhere and I get whatever I'll get a
good meal I'll get a legit meal but I
want to dessert yeah I want molt does
that you do put it in a ziploc bag yeah
puffs not not even you carry on by the
way then you gotta bring a shaker yeah
right there's this multiple problems
that I have I've got to figured I'll
figure out a system one thing I can't
say is to is when I when I I've always
if I drink protein shakes in the past I
would have to use a big shaker and put a
lot put probably 16 ounces of milk
forever one thing that's good about milk
and cuz that's the only way you feel
satisfied with mochi you can use one of
the small little shakers so this is a
possibility I'm creating ideas ready I
can bring one of the small shakers bring
a little bit of milk in it and then just
hit it up will be good
yeah cuz you don't need a big giant
shaker cuz you don't need to drink that
much milk to feel like it like it like
you got enough dessert anyway back to
the deal emerging camp yeah it's coming
August through September 2nd this is
weird but we might it looks like we
might actually sell out at a certain
point how do you sell out of the can
think we so if you want to come get
registered because it we're probably
gonna end up because you can look wheat
we have we already bought more Matt's
double the Matt so we had to muster yeah
it's a lot of Matt's but still I mean
there's still a limit yeah so if you
want to come to that come I'll be there
echo we there Dave Burke will be there
lay fab and I'll be there JPS on the
fence
Dean Lister Dean list will be there sure
yeah yeah that's good it we're you know
when you learn stuff at they I mean
there's there you know there's there
you're gonna learn specific things from
specific people and all that stuff but
don't look at it like this thing where
you're gonna go and you're just gonna
learn what they have to teach you you
know they're gonna teach you sliders are
just like the 15 or 20 black belts there
yes so on top of that if you made it
your goal if you win and you went and
you said went to each one of those 15
black belts and said show me your move
your best move yeah if you did that and
he walked away
that would be that would be solid yeah
and but you you couldn't this is not
this isn't a hey show me your move and
you spend three minutes no I'm talking
if you see if you spent like an hour
maybe even hour and a half going over
what's your best move like I bet I could
teach certain moves for an hour and a
half and just show every little detail
if you came to the immersion camp and
that's what you did you'd be walking out
of there CSUN if it'd be rough if
everyone did that because you know the
art yeah I don't think I don't think you
could logistically do it but I will say
this that on top of what all the
instructors there and not to mention
just other experienced people what they
have to offer and teach you you can come
and be like hey my rear naked choke
needs work yeah oh yeah this is how I do
it eight chocolate come here this is how
I do it this is all day by the way you
have this opportunity how I do it and
show well that's that's one thing that
you could do because you can't just
literally train the entire time but you
can get shown
and you can work moves oh yeah you can't
just train cuz you'll die if but the
point is there though where you can come
and you can come to emerging camp right
and it's good again to learn from from
everything that one has to teach but you
can go in with specific like questions
up with your game where are used to like
oh for sure how am I gonna get better of
course my Jesus is gonna get better in
general that's good
of course but if it's like wait will my
mount if you if your mount escape to get
better and that's what your focus on
nothing you can ask actually well I'll
give you this advice if you have trouble
being mounted and escaping them out a
good person to ask about that is
actually echo Charles you have a very
good mount escape oh yes very teachable
that's one of your best moves is that
amount escape I will say that right now
authoritative Lee Brian OH
got a good mount escape thanks bruh also
shifting gears so yeah anyway emerging
camp August 26 to September 2nd origin
mein kampf or all that crap that we just
talked about yeah or do you mean main
like the state and ma I
yeah or JEP mean calm also if you want
to get these cool shirts that say
discipline equals freedom Jaco is a
store it's called Jaco store so go to
Jocko store.com they anyway that's where
you can get the shirts to say display
freedom get after it anyway if you want
to represent with Jaco gear it's more
the philosophy it's not Jocko gear
doesn't really have your face on it or
nothing all wait yes it does have your
face on it and it says good one of them
maybe two one two I don't know anyway go
there chuckle store calm if you like
something get something you want to
represent in your town also rash guards
on their hoodies on their t-shirts rash
guards truckers hats you like the Flex
fit let's say I don't know wear hats
I don't because you're bald yeah my head
could hit a tan but actually I did I
went in phases not to go to do you said
you were gonna get me much more of these
truckers hats and you did not
which one does this was real yeah or
deaf court deaf Korea oh they're on the
way
don't you mean braided right now okay
actually I added like a bonus color of
the I don't support bonus colors a bonus
no but it's like a khaki uh like a like
a brown like a 1000 trois going tactic
all right anyway chuckles heard a lot of
good stuff do you just stuff on their
women's stuff on there I have to mean
he's whatnot some posters on there too
by the way
oh no about that who trying to run it
today yeah like it cuz a lot of people
and I mean for real a lot of people like
a lot a lot is that like seven what are
the posters of this vehicles freedom and
the good poster those are the ones that
people would hit me up often very often
be like hey my gym
I want to post her I want to post her
for my room I want to post her from my
office you know 24 by 36 posters there's
two posters on there I'll make other
other ones but yeah that's some post
show actually boom represent in your gym
in your office in your home I go into my
home first thing when you walk in it's
interesting a poster of our podcast did
good poster that's cool yeah so your
face is kind of sort of there you know
representing in my house thanks Junko
by the way also good way to support the
podcast is to subscribe to the podcast
on iTunes and Google Play stitcher
wherever you listened to two podcasts
interesting oh there's so many of them
out there now there's a lot of podcasts
no platform sorry yeah there's a lot of
podcasting there's a lot of podcast
platforms yes it's the new media new
media new media voice yeah it is voice
it it is voice also in addition to this
podcast mm-hmm which is called the
jockle podcast there's also the warrior
kid podcast which is for kids but I
promise you can get a lot out of it as
an adult too cool thing I've been doing
on that I've done it twice I'm gonna do
it more but so it's questions for uncle
Jake is the basic premises a premise of
it but now I have stories from Uncle
Jake and the stories from uncle Jake are
actually from uncle Jake's childhood and
they kind of teach a lesson to people
yeah so that's number podcast number 14
and 15 are the first two that I've
started doing stories from Uncle Jake so
I think people will like those yeah
they're little yeah they're good
some so this kind of like character
development sprinkled in there with
bless to me the lesson one and I'm maybe
this is intentional but the lesson is
the primary of course and it's deep same
they're very consistent with the whole
Uncle Jake lesson that the idea is I'm
explaining how Uncle Jake got his values
yeah from experiences that he went
through as a child yeah and they're the
stories are five minutes eight minutes
something like that they're there
they're pretty short stories but they're
cool yeah they're enjoyable so warrior
kid podcast you can check that one out
it's it's good and if kids if your kids
have questions for Uncle Jake just hit
me up on Twitter yeah send them to
Twitter and I'll capture them yep good
one also YouTube subscribe to the
YouTube channel we do have a YouTube
channel if you're interested in the
video version of this podcast or if you
see echoes editing skills sure some
people say you went over the top
sure so you there's a video called
warpath it's a it's probably the most
controversial video from my perspective
cuz it was originated with Christmas
music which I don't like Christmas music
and echo made with Christmas music and
you put a lot of time and effort into it
on Christmas so if we want to talk
leadership here like from my perspective
I knew you've been working really hard
on this thing and then you showed it to
me and then the Christmas music kicked
in which I didn't like didn't match but
you know I just had to be like hey man
it's great I really appreciate you lots
of great video so I lied to you is that
a lie you did it say great no you did
not lie okay said and I quote
interesting choice of music for this one
that's it you know I also will say that
I don't 100% trust myself like I'd think
to myself well echo really liked
Christmas music so he put it in there
so that's fine if that maybe some other
people will like it too and that's I'm
not here to like dictate what people
like and don't like I'm just here to
tell you what I like and don't like yes
but then you but then you read it the
video with with more appropriate music
sure which is good
sure but but then some people said you
got crazy you went too far with it look
you went to for you too much stuff
exploded you got too much stuff going on
there is the same amount of explosion I
know what I'm saying I never really paid
too much attention to what people say
because I couldn't even get past the
music once I got past the music and I
checked that YouTube comments
which I know right yeah you know I went
there and people some people the
majority of people you said amazing
right the mature some people just threw
it out there hey take it easy breh yeah
yeah you can taste it you can't you
crossed the line alright if you went
over the line I'm I think you were
around the line yeah I think you might
have you know step the toes a little bit
but we have to find out where the line
is right yes and I think you did a good
job of pressing up against mine without
dis gaem well let me let me tell you the
philosophy in turn and tell me if this
is a good way to approach it so a lot of
those videos okay so consider the first
one we did good
right it's the first one for it okay
good out of the gate I think I might
have told the story like there's a story
behind but we were recording paka it was
like number three or five one of the
first initial ones and I was like oh my
camera was sitting over there behind
kind of behind over in the in the corner
and if you notice on good one it shows
you you can see like it's behind like a
monitor and so you can see this die I
just went and pressed I kind of moved
the camera a little bit and I just press
record before you said that that part
and I was like oh I'm gonna record this
just in case on me I'll make a video out
of it or something or whatever and if
you look at I watch it the other day or
do like Joe Rogan guys we're talking
about it watch it you know and I
remember thinking and you're like
reading and when you're looking up like
you're looking at me and everything
the same this stuff to me and on my
father this is crazy I'm glad I'm
recording it but that wasn't me it
wasn't like okay we're gonna do this
we're gonna record this and we're gonna
do that you know it was just like I'm
gonna try to make a fun video out of it
then just put some random like graphics
on there that I was just having fun
doing so these videos you do it they're
kind of done out of just fun you know
and every one and every once in a while
hey man you have too much fun you grab
some sound effects and you make the
walls crumble you do kind of stuff you
know you have some fun with it I mean
there's no I guess there is kind of
their thematic I guess right there's
Amite to it like warpath like yeah it's
kind of for me it's like it's it's
pretty awesome to watch yeah it's just I
could see where you're like you I can
see where you start going down the path
of like just more is better and that's
really what happens and I'll catch
myself doing and it'll take a long as
I'm like brother it's not even necessary
and in fact and some people they will
bring up this point which is a good
point where I put stuff crumbling right
for okay warp out or take warpath for
example I put the walls crumbling and
Jaco and Dean rolling and when they when
they clash like the walls come
shattering down and saw these special
effects which is like cool when you look
at but all the special effects the sound
effects and like all this stuff is like
is it kind of getting in the way of the
message because the message is like
you're saying something specific you
know so it's kind of getting in the way
you know true so I gotta watch out for
that yeah and I think that's a good
point when people say that my dam that's
true and cuz you don't know when you're
the major course almost more stoked yeah
I guess but I ya got a 100 a there's
also a warrior kid YouTube channel okay
so the reason that we separated the
warrior kid and the warrior kid and the
jockle podcast channel channel blah blah
blah is because we know that there's
things on this podcast and on the
therefore on the youtube channel jockle
podcast there's stuff that's
inappropriate for children to listen to
or watch and so this is a way to
separate them so there's also a warrior
kid YouTube channel that your kid can
sit there and watch and and
hopefully I'm not guaranteeing because I
don't know how they algorithms work that
pop up the next video selections but
hopefully your kid can watch the warrior
kid videos without getting hooked into
the unit 731 testimony about you to the
section so watch out for that yep story
and I think caller too by the way yeah
Jake as it were yeah
also good way to support yourself is to
get some new gear if your workouts are
boring
gives me new gear from on it by the way
on it calm slash choco good place to go
good information to about starting your
kettlebell workout browse and I just
thought of this kid yesterday was in the
pool with my daughter and my wife was
saying you know you know how like okay
so you might seem like BJ Penn do this
where he'll go in the bottom of the
ocean and I'll carry this rocking that
rotten Hawaii yeah yeah that's how so
I'm like hey you could grab one of those
kettlebells for sure and and my daughter
she's five so she's like yeah I was like
yeah I'll go grab the little it's like
it's like it's like a pixie you know I
don't know I don't know what it is but
it's like one of those legend bells yeah
yeah that's a smaller net that I got for
so she grabs it and she goes in the pool
she's like I'm gonna say yeah walk to
the other side and it's like D it's she
goes kinda into the deep suction so she
goes and she's carrying it she's doing
the whole Japan with the little
kettlebell she's five by the way under
the water and we're watching it were
like oh that's cute but she starts to
sort of run out of air and she don't
want to drop the kettlebell because it's
like gonna slam on the bottom of a pool
and I don't know maybe she just she's
five she didn't think of that you know
kind of thing so I see her trying to
like swim with it like trying to get to
the top and it's kind of deep and I was
like oh I started to get worried and
then she started a little bit more
urgency so I had to jump in grab her
echo with the save save but she did
right when I got tore she put it up on
the little there's a little ledge on the
other side of the pool there she managed
to do it just but just barely so I went
in there with my middle daughter was
probably eight eight years old and we
had a party at the beach for her
birthday or
and so I was dealing with I could as
long as I could I was dealing with the
games and or whatever and finally I'm
like you know what that's it we're going
we're gonna get some so we formed the
party up into two teams and we're gonna
compete against each other in obstacle
courses and sprints and all this other
stuff and this particular location has a
river a gentle flowing tidal river that
comes out and anyways one of the contest
I had was okay you so we got a swim
across and there's big rocks and stuff
and I'm gonna swim across the river and
come back and whoever brings back the
biggest rock is the winner
so my middle daughter is topped off
she's tough and she's strong she's a
wrestler and gymnastics and all that
crap
yeah we're not crap but all that stuff
you know like she's just she's a beast
and she's mentally like um I don't want
to use the term psycho but like she's
real determined about stuff so anyways
this is what she's a little kid you know
and so go go across the river and
whoever brings back the biggest rock
wins so she goes so they all go across
and kids are grabbing rocks that are
size of let's say let's say a softball
mm you know maybe a softball What's in
between the size of a softball and a
soccer ball I don't know some so
something okay loaf of bread like like
maybe a small loaf of bread that's the
max right that any of these kids are
grabbing my daughter grabs something
that's like the size of a like a legit
watermelon like giant giant giant rock
to hand o to hand drunk robbed giant
rock like a four or five loaves of bread
just a big big giant rock and I'm
watching it I'm thinking oh she's gonna
say to the bottom and so I have to let
it go and stuff to go back and get a
smaller one maybe she can still do okay
so she's come and the river has weird
contours on the bottom you know you're
you're you can walk a little while then
it just drops super deep and you got to
make it yeah so I'm watching her and
she's she's
Harper even carry it and and she carries
he gets that deep section just drops
down goes under and I'm waiting for her
to pop up but she doesn't pop up and I'm
waiting for to pop up and she doesn't
pop up and I'm waiting for a pop up and
she doesn't pop up and then I see like
an air bubble come up and I'm like oh
day but the air bubble has progressed so
now I'm watching the air bubbles like
progress yeah they're coming closer to
the other side and and then it starts to
come up and sure enough out she comes
like a like a beast powered through that
and brings the rock up drops it at my
feet victory is yours
that's that's actually pretty powerful
because Braille when you're I mean
unless she was like depends on her
mindset so her she was probably like I'm
not gonna let this Rock defeat me I'm
gonna bring it to the other side and
that's kind of the mindset I'm not gonna
drop it for that reason I think my
daughter it was like I'm can't drop this
thing so I'm stuck with it
he's a kind of thing that's what you
know so she started you could tell she
was a little bit going into panic mode
yeah yeah so it's a whole different
scenario technically but that's pretty
savage though do you think that I should
because she's probably she's scared she
even said like later like oh that was
like scary and all this stuff I should
probably make her do it again oh yeah
yeah like not make her like do it jump
in there my daughter my youngest
daughter did the big cliff jump
yesterday in long swim in the ocean to
open open ocean waters no you gotta get
him and she was I was I thought she was
gonna be panicky yeah cuz it's big
dropping its ocean and whatever and this
is what's one way of action yeah but she
was I said are you good and she said
yeah you do yeah yeah yeah that you just
I mean unless she got traumatized by it
or something like this yeah we're brown
Mike it's weird
come from Hawaii jump off everything you
don't want right so we have this ledge
you know that you know you saw it and
it's not that high but for a
one-year-old it's pretty high
my boy and my daughter once used one too
they just jump off we catch him I can't
swim yet you know and my son he jumped
off a few times and was all good but
then one time he went to walk and
there's this little just a slight little
dip and you know when you're you know
you're new to walk he slipped he tripped
and he fell in i caught him but he
full-on like he decide on the edge of
the thing and he's Ginny's crying he's
won and just just over one maybe made
him do it again he didn't want to do it
though but so I didn't like push him
again
I just kept like hey do it I got you I
got you and he'd be like you know crying
or whatever and then you know my
daughter would do it I would do it then
he finally like reluctantly did it and
we cheered for him and now he's all good
good girl like forces himself he makes
me catch him now he's like almost two
anyway but yeah the point is you make
him do it again right yeah but you're
very accurate and saying don't
traumatize him yeah you going right now
ah come off now it's just getting worse
you're not you're not yeah you know it's
like the hey do it you should do it oh
you want to take a little break that's
okay but you know you should definitely
do this as if you've already done it
before
you don't want to traumatize him worse
yeah yeah
that's not gonna work out good yeah
especially with the water man cuz it's
like it's one minute it's all fun and
games and literally your mind can flip
to like I'm about to die I used to say
this so in the 90s in the SEAL Teams
when there was no war going on and
whatever you'd go out and you do
training ah there was times I would
always tell guys when you're working the
water it's a real world mission like we
didn't know what a real world mission
I've never been on one but the fact of
the matter is when you're working with
the water it's a real world mission
because if you screw something up you
can easily die easily if you're not
careful one up one down just gonna throw
it out there if you're doing any kind of
this training and you're training the
water one person stays up on the surface
the other person you know in and be a
lifeguard you don't do the simultaneous
training in the water so just throwing
that out there was a little safety note
for everyone yes one up one down
that's the rule yes and especially if
you're carrying the kettlebells
from on it or otherwise at the bottom of
the pool the bottom of the ocean
in the bottom of a reservoir bottom of
any body of water yeah
one up one down I'm going down war
nonetheless so that's how we utilize the
pixie
I think it's called pixie it's one of
the legend bells anyway if I guess that
doesn't really have much to do with what
on it offers but it just I just thought
of that cuz it just happened
nonetheless hey he was represented in
the story boom indeed anyway if you want
cool fitness stuff on it calm slash
chuckle a lot of good information on
there some socks on there I mentioned
the socks like it's like this big deal
and here's the thing it is on it socks
of the TSA the other day I just uh not
on it sucks
yeah issues you know they were looking
they're like those are dope socks
anyway uh nakhon slash chocolate it's a
good spot a psychological warfare is an
album that you can get where I talk
about stuff of overcoming when you have
little moments of weakness and I'm gonna
make another one good and make another
one got a gum plotting on it it looks
like it's gonna be called all your
excuses are lies yes good night good
title you get that iTunes Google Play
whatever and also chocolate white tea
people have now seen that we have cans
of jockle white tea where do you get
them you get them on Amazon if you want
them it tastes awesome you can get the
dry tea on there too which you add water
to and then you brew it and then if
either one you're gonna get a 8000 pound
deadlift so that's cool do that got some
books waiting the warrior kid and marks
mission two books which one do you like
better do I like better I can't say
because the first one the og the
original one from wimpy to warrior will
always have that's the one that
established the establishes the ethos in
my house anyway but you know I can't say
I think they're both outstanding but
it's good how you evolve the issues yeah
it's like full basic think about how
many people like all you're gonna write
more well yeah what are you writing
about think about all the issues you
have as a human being and then you talk
about
you should you add as a kid yeah like
we're gonna cover all those yeah that's
like ten books right uncle Jake's got
some help for you yeah so yeah way the
warrior kid books the the one thing
that's cool is people as a parent you're
like man how do I get my kid to even
something as stupid as cleaning your
room right how do you get your kid to
clean your room having read this book I
got pictures I got a picture on Twitter
the other day kids kind of vacuum
cleaner yeah and the dad's apartment
look at this that's a real thing even as
um like okay so kids can read the book
of course but I read it to my daughter
who's four at the time for yeah so I'm
reading it and it's answering a bunch of
questions I have so it's like hey you
know my kid you know my daughter's okay
oh you mean parenting course yes and
it's just little stuff little stuff
sometimes you won't even really think up
so like okay for example and I said I
mentioned this in before but is a huge
deal that I still use it like it's not
up front on my mind every single time so
you know how like you'll have a kid and
they'll be like real good at something
just kind of right away maybe your kids
more athletic or something maybe they're
bigger taller or whatever so they kind
of win real quick you know so when they
run into a situation where they're in an
activity that actually requires practice
and like a cartwheel or something like
this and so my daughter she's being she
the athletic little girl way bigger
she's that you know and so she has this
friend same age she's like a week either
older a younger I forget but they're the
same age and she can do a cartwheel and
just fly through cartwheels one-handed
cartwheels all this stuff this other
girl can she's way smaller you know way
whatever so my daughter she doesn't like
that not the fact that the girl can but
just she can you know so she tries to do
it totally so that she can so it's it's
very upsetting
so uncle Jake said something in the
first one that this will always stick
one she complains to me about it can't
do a cartwheel in how much you can do a
cartwheel but I can and all this stuff I
say and I quote uncle Jake how do you
expect to be good at something when
you've never practiced boom just like
the times table yeah are you gonna be
done in time sir what you never studied
you know and
makes it known how to do a cartwheel
foreign known how to do a cartwheel just
like how you know our other neighbor can
play the guitar you know much practice
you know kind of thing and it's crazy
because just that simple line right
there I choose for and she understands
you know she's like practicing but
anyway that's how that's all that book
is then war your kid books there's two
of them where the warrior kid and marks
mission you can get those you can also
get discipline equals freedom the Field
Manual field manual how to get after it
simple as that the audio version of that
is not on audible it's on iTunes Amazon
music all that stuff also extreme
ownership extreme ownership is on
audible and I just looked it was number
two on Apple audible books whatever
that's called Apple iBooks or something
number two right now folks been out for
almost three years
what is Apple iBooks it's where you can
get books for your eye
yeah audiobooks are key yeah oh speaking
of books by the way if you want to get
this one oh unit 731 third testimony
yeah
I'm putting on the land unit 731 just
that yeah oh that subtitle is Japan's
secret biological warfare in World War
two yeah dark book but see really see
strongly a feel strongly that that's
like one you can o honor the whole thing
yeah it's crazy but yeah anyway I'm
gonna put them out on our website
chuckle podcast no someone just hit me
up on Twitter that he's okay we we had a
long road trip for fourth of July my
wife me and my kids aged you know 13
whatever listen to 121 122 and 123 yeah
that's real significant you know I don't
wanna say it family time but like that's
a real the compared to the other things
you could be doing in the car that's a
real good thing to do in your car
introduce your kids to better history a
bit of human nature a bit of the
darkness of the world a bit of
overcoming that darkness that's pretty
cool
these are the kind of books well so
that's that but yeah these book
you're saying these kind of books you
kind of want to have it's I think it's
important to I think it's important to
know what's going on and know what has
happened in the world as I said yeah you
want to check that out
yeah but yeah I put it on the on the
website that's the point
I'm have a or we have it on the page
books from the episodes all by episode
systems from obviously 133 yep and and
also you've got on the website because
extreme ownership which I talked about
is the first book I wrote with my
brother late famine and we wrote another
book which is called the dichotomy
leadership that's also on the website
right yes yeah and pull yeah so that's
that's coming out September 25th if you
want to get that on the first dish you
can go for the third dish if you want
though who it's a difference between
third and third edition in seventh
edition nothing it's the same what's the
difference between first a dish and
second a dish
well it's you were in the game yes so
it's kind of like the difference if you
take if you run a race or if you're
recognized not recognized but let's say
you run a race you first okay first
place guy second place third place die
you all get medals what is what is the
medal made out of we'll just say metal
for lack of a better term what's the
difference between the metal gold
no nothing only the collar psychological
oh it's all made of the same stuff bad
analogy
yeah I don't even follow it but all
right first edition that's the point
that's all get it on I'm talking to be
first year and also if you want to bring
myself
Lafe Babb and JP Danelle Dave Burke we
got Mike Sorelli got Flint Cochran now
on the team if you need help with
leadership in your organization whatever
kind of organization it is you can hit
us up a tional on front is the name of
the company we solve problems through
leadership national on front dot-com
juju ssam we have one more muster in
2018 it is in San Francisco it's October
17th and 18th it's gonna sell out I was
I just got an update from
Jamie today the office director and I
still on front an insurer
she was saying that we're gonna sell out
a lot sooner than we thought so if you
want to come up there extreme ownership
calm the muster up I got a video to post
about that too
I haven't posted it yet but yeah that's
that also on top of the muster we have
the roll call which is for police
military law enforcement firefighters
and first responders it's for people in
uniform
that's happening September 21st in
Dallas Texas it's only one day so you
don't have to miss me too much work it's
a lower price point so you can afford it
or you can get your organization to pay
for it a little easier come on down to
that it's a great program I just
finished putting together the agenda
yesterday and so come on down
until then if you want to kick it with
us it's a little bit more virtually
until we are together live which we will
be will be together live at the muster
in San Francisco or at the roll call in
Dallas Texas or or at the immersion camp
in Maine we'll see you at one of those
but until then if you do want to kick it
with us we will be on the interwebs on
Twitter on Instagram and on - face a
Pokeball echo is that echo Charles and I
am at Jocko willing and of course to all
the military personnel that are
listening you provide the freedom that
allows us to do what we do every day you
also hold the line against the evil that
we talked about today so thank you to
police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics Border Patrol other first
responders you actually provide this
safety that allows us to do what we do
every day so thanks to you and to the
families that support all those that
serve thank you for supporting those
families that serve and everyone else
that's listening thank you for listening
thanks for supporting I know it was a
rough listen
it's rough for me to read it's rough for
me to talk about but it's also reality
and if you don't face reality you can't
fix it if you don't face your past you
can't learn from it so what you have to
do is you have to face them you have to
face what scares you you have to face
what bothers you you have to face your
weaknesses and face your fears and face
your own darkness face them own them and
overcome them all by stepping up and
getting after it and until next time
this is echo and Jocko out